my hand  you know grazed his face and i knew  right away so  i knew right away i had caught some part  of his head so  i went over to apologize to him and  obviously  you guys seen what happened after that  but  definitely  accidental  i mean just like the  you know to play last night on russ  accidental hitting the mouth just like  some owners play tonight  you know accidentally to the high you  know  definitely i'm not the type of player so  you know i hate to see that um what  escalated after that  um i didn't think it warned uh  i thought it warranted an objection  because of them  of what happened after that  you know having me probably still in the  game and excitement from the fans  what could possibly happen after that  obviously but  a suspension i didn't think there was uh  i didn't think it was warranted but the  league made that call  and we are good